there is no stopping the most dedicated
it's a cold wet morning in this rust
belt corner of pennsylvania
they're here in their hundreds for a
presidential appearance only announced
at the weekend
we're looking forward to seeing the
president i am so excited i'm like
shaken
do you feel your life has been made
better over the past four years
absolutely
why is that all the opportunities the
jobs
he's done great things i love trump i
think he's a fighter
i think he plays dirty sometimes but he
fights for the values i believe in what
are you handing out
sanitizer okay are you worried about
kovac
no i've forgotten men and women the
campaign videos are on a loop
but they're not necessary
really clear talking to people here is
that they haven't come down here to make
up their minds they're not undecided
they are utterly convinced
that trump's their man
[Applause]
[Music]
his arrival as always is filled with a
feel-good patriotism
okay who has not voted yet
who doesn't intend to vote who's not
going to vote
oh you better say that you'd be in big
trouble in this car
so who is going to vote for trump
so it's clear from the rally that donald
trump has been hugely effective in
making people
feel better but are their lives actually
any better lehigh county was won by
clinton in 2016
just but the neighboring counties they
swung to trump
this is just the sort of place where a
few votes either way
will make all the difference not far
from the rally at blocker's coffee house
so what happens 15 years that's the
answer
we meet michael and vince so i see his
policies as
houses of cards uh things built on sand
that aren't solid
i think he's a con man i think he talks
a good talk i think at the end of the
day he can't walk the walk
it's interesting that two guys like us
that live so close together
uh can see so things so differently uh i
i certainly see
things that trump has done
to help um
people that in the past were forgotten
is your life better
it's certainly no worse how about you
vince life better now than it was four
years ago
it's unsettling it it makes me kind of
embarrassed to be an american honestly
so my understanding is we could have
listened all day
they may be divided but here at least
it's amicable
and the passion is all american
this election isn't about changing minds
it'll come down to turn out in the end
how many more can be drawn to each side
mark stone sky news in pennsylvania